Chaos had erupted, all hell had broken loose,
and nightmares were running amok.
Even from her perspective, watching as fleshy
abominations tore through the streets of New
York City, Eliza Flynn couldn’t escape the
feeling that the entire world had gone mad.
Only moments before, things had been calm,
normal, another mundane, uninteresting day
in the Big Apple.
Now, she was watching in horror from underneath
an overturned table as a group of… things
had seemingly appeared out of nowhere.
Unbeknownst to Eliza, these creatures were
instances of something known as SCP-610, alternatively
going by the name the Flesh that Hates.
From her hiding place, inside the local coffee
shop she frequented, they looked like horrific,
mutated masses of flesh that barely resembled
anything even close to human.
But that’s what they were… or at least,
had been.
Eliza had witnessed a barista rushing out
into the street, trying to get away from a
group of SCP-610s that were bashing their
appendages against the front window.
In trying to make a break for it, the mutated
creatures attacked the barista, killing him
upon making contact with his skin.
It was only a short while afterwards that
Eliza spotted his body moving, the infectious
process only accelerated by the heat from
a nearby car that was on fire.
Before long, what had once been a barista,
an ordinary person, was now another of the
grotesque Flesh monsters.
Mike, she remembered, his name had been Mike.
She’d read it on his nametag when she came
in for her morning coffee.
He had always smiled, never got the spelling
of her name right on her to-go cup, writing
it with an ‘S’ instead of a ‘Z’.
And now he was gone.
Worse than just dead, he wasn’t even Mike
anymore, instead turned into another SCP-610
monstrosity.
Too petrified to move, terrified of being
caught and turned into another of the fleshy
nightmares, Eliza stayed hidden.
This was it, she thought to herself, any moment
now, one of those things would find her, either
breaking through the street-facing window
of the coffee shop, or slithering in through
the rear fire door.
Sure enough, the Flesh formerly known as Mike
the barista turned.
Where had once been a head was now a featureless
blob that had fused with the shoulder, but
Eliza could tell its eyeless stare was being
directed at her… and she had nowhere to
run.
Mike’s arm, which was now a slimy, blood-red
tentacle, began slamming against the glass,
cracks forming across the surface.
Eliza’s eyes darted around the room, trying
to look for some kind of way out.
Her options were limited, and even then, they
didn’t amount to more than hiding in a storage
cupboard and prolonging the inevitable.
She needed a miracle.
As if to answer her prayers, a blinding white
light erupted from somewhere out of view,
beyond the window.
Turning away, Eliza had to shield her eyes
from the searing glow, blinking away spots
in her vision as she looked to see what had
happened.
The SCP-610 creature – Mike – had vanished,
a dark outline scorched against the glass,
as if it had been obliterated by an intense
focused blast.
That light, whatever it was, had vaporized
it.
The sound of commotion came bustling through
the door, and distorted, mechanical-sounding
voices calling out.
“Hello?
Is anyone in here?”
one garbled.
“We mean you no harm,” another said.
“But you need to leave this place, as soon
as you can.”
Cautiously, Eliza stood up from under the
table.
Standing at the entrance to the coffee shop
were a trio of figures.
Each one of them had machinery, all manner
of metallic components protruding from their
bodies, replacing arms, legs, parts of their
faces.
Eliza stared at them, unsure whether these
cyborgs were as harmless as they claimed;
one even had a cannon in place of one of their
hands, which was still smoking from the blast
that had killed the SCP-610 outside.
“Did the Flesh make contact with you?”
one of the figures asked.
“No,” Eliza replied.
“That’s how they spread, right?
It’s like an infection…
I watched it happen.”
“Indeed,” the cyborg with the cannon arm
replied.
“The Flesh being loose is only the beginning.
If you are uninfected, then we’d ask you
to come with us.
We’ll explain on the way.”
“Hang on, who are you?”
Eliza asked, concern on her face.
“And where are you taking me?”
“We’re the Church of the Broken God,”
one of them answered.
“And we’re getting you out of New York.”
The idea of a person making their way out
of the City That Never Sleeps on foot would
be laughable to anyone that lived there, even
before it had become overrun with monsters.
But the subway wasn’t exactly running on
time, and the roads were gridlocked with cars
that had either been destroyed or abandoned
by their owners.
So, walking out of New York was the only option.
The Church of the Broken God cyborgs explained
to Eliza as much as they knew about what had
happened.
They described an organization, a secret cabal
with power spanning the entire world called
the SCP Foundation.
Apparently, this Foundation had been responsible
for gathering and safeguarding the world from
dangerous and unexplained phenomena.
“You mean like those Flesh things?”
she asked.
“Exactly, they called those SCP-610.”
But recently, something had changed.
The Foundation had turned its seemingly inexhaustible
resources to the goal of exterminating humanity.
It was by their hands that instances of SCP-610
had been unleashed in major cities; not just
New York, but Delhi, Tokyo, London, and countless
others.
Those were far from the only anomalies the
Foundation had deployed either, as they walked
the cyborgs described how someone called ‘Mr
Deeds’ had been assassinated heads of state
the world over.
They also spoke of a horrifying reptile that
was now running wild and slaughtering everything
in its path.
“We at the Church had to act.
Whatever the Foundation’s reasons for unleashing
this hell, we couldn’t sit by and allow
them to destroy everything.
So, we’ve aligned ourselves with the Global
Occult Coalition, to assist them in fighting
against the Flesh that Hates.
In exchange, we have vowed to help transport
survivors to safety.”
“But where can we possibly go that’s safe?”
Eliza interjected.
“If the Foundation have the reach you say
they do, and if they have all these…
horrible creatures at their disposal, then
what chance do we have at surviving.”
“Well, there is always our path,” one
of the Broken God’s followers replied.
“The path of Standardisation, becoming one
with machine.
Our mechanized parts are safe from the Flesh’s
corruption.
If you would consider joining us…”
Eliza took a quick glance at the metallic
components of her cyborg companions; they
looked like they hurt as much as becoming
a SCP-610 monster would have.
She politely declined, although it led to
the rest of their journey continuing in an
awkward silence.
Eventually, the Broken God cyborgs brought
Eliza to an extraction point where they left
her in the care of the Global Occult Coalition.
Boarding a convoy, her and a number of others
were ferried out of New York state by the
GOC.
For the first time since this had all started,
Eliza started to think that maybe she was
heading to somewhere safe.
That sliver of hope all came crashing down
the moment the convoy was attacked.
Armed assailants opened fire on the trucks.
They were quickly identified by Coalition
soldiers as members of the SCP Foundation’s
Mobile Task Forces, special operations troops
sent out to pick off survivors.
In the midst of the firefight, gunfire erupting
all around her, Eliza had never felt so terrified.
One of the GOC officers turned to her as they
crouched behind cover.
“Listen, I should be telling you this, but
there’s rumors of a survivor settlement
not far from here!” he barked.
“I’ll draw their fire.
You run.
Get as far away from here, fast as you can,
and don’t look back!”
Doing as he told, Eliza sprinted away from
the wreckage of the convoy, until her legs
refused to run any further.
She trudged alone through an empty town, abandoned;
it felt like a place out of a nightmare.
The world was decimated, virtually post-apocalyptic.
The further she willed herself to walk, the
more she could feel herself giving up that
she would ever find the settlement, if it
even existed at all.
Hope had abandoned her, and at her lowest
point, Eliza dug her heels in and dropped
to the ground, both exhausted and convinced
she’d been hiking towards nothing.
The feeling of being moved caused Eliza to
stir, waking her up from a dream that had
been almost as bleak as her new reality.
Someone was carrying her on what felt like
a stretcher, she quickly realized.
Before she had a chance to ask who they were,
the pair of shadowy human shapes brought her
through the woods to what looked like a campsite.
“Don’t be alarmed,” one of them said
in a voice that sounded so optimistic it felt
almost alien; as if this person was from another
planet where things were far less horrible.
Looking around, Eliza noticed the glow of
a campfire illuminating the nearby trees.
A handful of people were huddled together
in makeshift tents, resting and wearing contented,
almost…
happy expressions.
Then, Eliza’s eyes were drawn towards something
else, some slimy mass gliding around the camp.
At first, she thought it was another instance
of SCP-610, until she saw an amorphous, gelatinous
orange blob glowing in the firelight.
To the Foundation, it had been known as SCP-999,
but to its newfound family of human survivors,
this creature was their savior, a bastion
of hope and happiness in a devastated hellscape:
the Tickle Monster.
Welcomed into the survivor community with
open arms, Eliza was soon exposed to SCP-999’s
anomalous effects.
The creature seemed to warm to her instantly,
greeting her with the enthusiastic friendliness
of a small dog.
Even after as little as a single interaction
with it, she felt her lack of hope and depressed
feelings towards the bleakness of the world
had almost entirely faded.
She felt happiness, pure, genuine happiness,
for the first time in recent memory.
Thanks to the Tickle Monster, Eliza’s entire
outlook had completely changed.
The same was true for the other survivors
that had formed a settlement around the happy
orange creature.
They had all come seeking an escape, not just
a physical place that was out of harm’s
way, but somewhere they could reject the harsh
reality of what the SCP Foundation had done
to the world.
And SCP-999 had provided that for them all,
curing the displaced refugees of their woes,
keeping them in perpetually high spirits.
Most of them had reached such a point of contentment
that they’d forgotten their old lives before
the collapse, before the anomalies and the
Foundation.
Although the Tickle Monster demanded nothing
of its newfound family, apart from the occasional
playful tickle wrestle, Eliza and a group
of the other survivors would venture back
to the nearby abandoned town just beyond the
woods.
Once there, they would scavenge for as much
food as they could find, keeping a close eye
out for any candy with which to feed SCP-999.
Even though they knew 999 was more than happy
to provide positivity to the survivors, each
of them felt it was the least they could do
for their favorite orange slime ball.
There was such a continuous state of love
and happiness in their camp that the survivors
were hardly phased when a Foundation soldier
inadvertently stumbled upon their settlement.
Before he could raise his weapon and fire,
SCP-999 slid between its friends and the soldier,
blocking the path of his bullets.
Without any shred of malice or hostility,
the delightful blob leaped towards the attacking
MTF operative and embraced him.
Instantly, the Foundation foot soldier’s
demeanor changed.
Before he had been glassy-eyed, emotionless,
like something deep inside him had broken.
But after their hug parted, the man was euphoric,
grinning in a state of elation for long afterwards.
For a time, Eliza sat with the soldier – Sergeant
Callows – and listened to him explaining
how he wanted to renounce the Foundation,
to stay with this community of survivors now
he knew SCP-999 was here.
“Do you remember anything from before?”
she asked curiously.
“Before?”
Callows echoed.
“You mean before the Foundation…
did all this?”
Eliza nodded; remembering the outside world
was hazy now, like trying to recall the vague
details of a dream.
“Not much,” the former MTF trooper answered.
“They wanted us to… to kill everyone because
of IT.”
“What, like the Stephen King book?”
“No,” Callows chuckled.
“They told us IT had latched itself on to
everyone, all human subconscious.
IT had plans, something really, really awful.
So, the Foundation’s plan was to wipe everyone
out.”
“Wouldn’t that include everyone who works
for the Foundation?”
“No, they… altered us, made it so we couldn’t
feel pain anymore,” he paused, then began
giggling uncontrollably, as if he’d just
understood the punchline to a joke.
“In fact,” Callows said between fits of
laughter, “That’s probably how 999 was
able to fix me.”
Next to him, Eliza couldn’t help but laugh
too, the humor was infectious.
“Because you couldn’t feel pain?”
she giggled.
“Yeah!”
Callows exploded, delighted tears rolling
down his face.
“I lost the capacity for it, I was hollowed
out, and that would’ve made it easy for
SCP-999 to fill that space with… this!”
He rolled over onto the floor, still chortling
unstoppably, and didn’t stop for hours.
The Tickle Monster’s powers of positivity
had increased exponentially since it had found
itself free from the Foundation facility it
had used to live at.
Much like Callow had explained to Eliza, it
had allowed the loveable blob to correct the
alteration the Foundation had made to the
former MTF sergeant, allowing him to feel
euphoria in the place of his total absence
of all pain.
And now, thanks to the influence of SCP-999,
the threat posed by both the SCP Foundation
and whatever this ‘IT’ entity was, seemed
so far away, so irrelevant, and did little
to dampen the high spirits of the survivors
in the camp.
But in their collective sense of bliss, Eliza,
SCP-999, and the other survivors became a
little oblivious to the outside world and
its horrors.
Little did they know, there was still danger
lurking much closer than they realized, one
that had spread from miles away, and would
very soon be at the settlement…
It was Eliza and Callow that first discovered
what was lurking nearby.
They had both been searching for food in the
ruins of the old town beyond the woods, which
felt more and more like a completely different
world the longer they spent in the camp with
SCP-999.
As Eliza rummaged through the storeroom of
an abandoned supermarket, she heard a scream
of agony coming from nearby: Callow.
For the first time in months, panic, fear,
and adrenaline rocked her system.
It almost made her feel sick.
She had been so overloaded with positive endorphins
that it had practically numbed her to all
other feelings.
But instinct kicked in, fight or flight hitting
her with the force of an ice-cold bucket of
water, and she ran out into the store to look
for Callow.
What she saw gave her a terrified knot in
her stomach, the kind she hadn’t felt since
the day the nightmare had started.
The Flesh that Hates, an instance of SCP-610,
was standing in the aisles of the empty supermarket.
The sight of the grotesque, mutated form shuffling
towards her made Eliza freeze on the spot.
It took a further moment to realize that Callow
had long since stopped screaming.
Eliza’s thoughts had picked up speed; for
the first time in months, she was processing
information without it being dulled by the
euphoria brought on by SCP-999.
It made her realize that this SCP-610 had
either killed Callow and he’d soon be turning
into one of the Flesh creatures… or this
was Callow, and he’d already changed.
Thinking fast, Eliza sprinted through the
supermarket, hearing the snarls of the Flesh
coming after her.
She passed a shopping cart, and in an instant,
grabbed its handlebar, turning the metal cage
around and racing full force towards the SCP-610
instance chasing her.
The cart collided with the blood-red mass
of Flesh, the sheer force knocking the creature
onto its back and giving Eliza a window of
opportunity to race out of the supermarket,
watched by a gaggle of mutated creatures.
Those of them that still had eyes followed
her movements as she ran back towards the
woods, towards the camp.
And slowly, the Flesh that Hates began to
follow.
From the moment that she returned to the settlement,
SCP-999 could immediately sense that Eliza
was in a state of panic.
Instinctively, the creature glided up to her,
only seeking to comfort her and make her forget
about whatever had troubled her.
“No, stop!”
she protested, as much as she wanted to not
worry about the impending danger.
SCP-999 recoiled from her, a wounded expression
on its gooey orange face.
“I’m sorry, it’s just we’re all in
serious trouble!”
Eliza urged.
The other survivors gathered around lazily,
each of them seeming upbeat despite her grave
news.
“The Flesh, SCP-610, they’re here.
They found us!”
she explained.
“They killed Callow, and it won’t take
them long to find us!”
“They won’t come here,” one of the other
survivors replied, not argumentatively, but
in a more uplifting and reassuring tone.
“None of the other anomalies have found
us in months,” another interjected, smiling.
“Not even the Foundation can get us here.
We’re protected.
Tickle Monster keeps us all safe.”
“But what if it can’t protect us from
the Flesh?”
Eliza desperately tried to warn her fellow
survivors, but they were in too much of a
carefree state to fear the approach of the
Flesh that Hates.
A number of them tried to convince her to
relax, spend some time with the Tickle Monster
so she wouldn’t feel as bad.
As appealing as that sounded, Eliza didn’t
want to let her guard down.
She felt she owed SCP-999 for keeping her
and the others alive, for helping them forget
the horrific world the Foundation had unleashed.
And, even if she was the only one, she’d
protect it.
Night had fallen, the sound of every snapping
twig felt like it could be one of the SCP-610s
approaching.
The rest of the camp was fast asleep, save
for Eliza, wielding a flaming branch in one
hand to ward off the Flesh.
Sure enough, through the shadows of the woods
and the low light of her torch, she saw shapes
begin to shuffle towards her.
The slick, bloody creatures looked even worse
in the dark, shambling over to Eliza, backing
away cautiously as she brandished her flame.
But the Flesh that Hates was closing in, more
and more of them slithering out of from between
the trees, causing her to step back in the
direction of the camp.
Suddenly, an excitable orange mass swept passed
Eliza.
Under the torchlight, she saw SCP-999 approaching
the fleshy mutations.
“No!”
she cried out, horrified at what they would
do to her camp’s protector.
To her surprise, the Flesh stopped in their
tracks as the Tickle Monster wiggled up to
them.
They seemed to get closer, examining the orange
goop as it grinned at them.
Then, as if they had all lost their innate
hostility to anything they hadn’t yet infected,
the SCP-610 creatures turned and left.
Perhaps it was something within the slimy
substance the Tickle Monster was made of that
repelled the Flesh that Hates.
Or maybe it was being such a sheer force of
overwhelming good, and its increased power
that allowed SCP-999 to pacify the monstrosities.
Either way, Eliza breathed a sigh of relief.
The grinning orange blob turned to her and
smiled, leaping up into her arms and allowing
her to carry it back to the camp, as SCP-999
turned her relief into happiness once again.
It seems that, no matter how bleak the world
might be, even in a timeline as horrifying
as that of SCP-5000, wherever the Tickle Monster
goes, there will always be the promise of
positivity… and with it, a sliver of hope
from the friendliest anomaly of all.
Now go and check out “SCP-999 THE TICKLE
MONSTER” for “WHAT IF SCP-999 WORE SCP-035?”
for more orange, blobby adventures!